- I'd like to also touch on a subject
that I think many doctors
and health organizations
are avoiding talking about
and that's how protests are
affecting COVID-19 numbers.
If you know me at all, I am
not a fan of fear-mongering.
You've heard me call out the
media time and time again
about the fact that they're
only after clicks and viewership
with the type of
fear-mongering they put out.
But I think it's about time
that I fear-monger you a little bit.
I gave us so much credit as
a nation in the beginning,
I would go on nationwide TV shows
and say there's so much
unity around COVID.
And now, I don't know what happened
over these last few weeks
but we threw social
distancing out the window.
We threw masks out the window
and we're no longer being alert,
we're no longer being proactive.
And what's happening?
COVID cases are spiking, people are dying,
and the second wave isn't even here yet.
18 states are experiencing
new highs of COVID-19 cases.
Six states have a spike greater
than 50% in their cases.
This is a huge problem folks.
Because the way we control COVID right now
is by being responsible, both you and me.
And that means keeping
six feet away from others.
That means wearing a mask at all times
where you're encountering other people.
Recently, I took a walk
around New York City
and I saw bars open.
I saw people standing next to each other,
talking with no masks in groups of 50.
We can't do this,
because the more we do it the
more people are gonna suffer,
especially because we
don't have a vaccine.
If you think it's bad now,
it can get a lot worse for the fall.
Many people have asked me
if vaccines are the answer to COVID-19
and while I have high
hopes for the vaccine,
I also have a few reservations.
Dr. Fauci, NIH, CDC have said
that the proposed timeline
if everything goes well early, 2021,
and that's the fastest
we've ever had a vaccine.
So while I'm hopeful it comes out then,
it's very easy for something to go wrong.
The vaccine not get created,
we see some harmful effects
and the timeline gets pushed.
Second, we don't know yet
the efficacy of this vaccine
because while there are several companies,
several trials, and several
different vaccines in play,
we don't know yet what percentage
of the time do these
vaccines actually work.
That is why I'm still urging
you to socially distance,
to wear a mask, to wash your hands
because you could be
standing next to someone
who looks completely healthy
and they could potentially
be getting you sick.
And going even further on this topic,
I wanna discuss something
that the WHO has said
which has made my blood boil.
The WHO issued this statement last week
and it confused a lot of people.
Take a listen.
- From the data we have,
it still seems to be rare
that an asymptomatic person
actually transmits onward
to a secondary individual.
- This confused everybody, even doctors.
We were all confused
as to which research
they were talking about.
Most people, like Joe
Rogan took it this way.
- Now this comes out today that was,
it basically said if you're asymptomatic,
you can't transfer it as
easily as they thought.
It's almost impossible.
- So all that worry
that we were about kids giving
it to their grandmothers,
they're not gonna do that.
- That was the only reason
why stores are shut down.
- This is a prime example of
poor scientific communication.
Let me explain.
Asymptomatic means something
different in technical terms
than it does to you or I.
This researcher was trying to explain
that those who are asymptomatic,
meaning aren't showing symptoms right now,
and will never show symptoms
don't usually spread COVID
but pre-symptomatic patients,
those who are asymptomatic right now
but will get sick later can
spread COVID quite quickly.
To scientists, pre-symptomatic
and asymptomatic are two different terms.
To you and I, they're the same thing.
The WHO quickly corrected this statement
and I understood the mistake
that they made, it happens.
As a large organization, that
is general-public-facing,
they need to do a better job
at clarifying these things.
We need to be able to trust the WHO.
I've consistently said on
this channel to trust the WHO.
YouTube pushes you to the WHO.
- Anything that would go
against World Health
Organization recommendations
would be a violation of our policy.
- So we need to not lose trust in them.
And the way that we do that
is for them to avoid mistakes
like this in the future.
And speaking of mistakes,
let's talk about my advice
on masks early on in this pandemic.
Here's a clip of me from
mid-February talking about masks
and pay close attention
to the words that I use.
The CDC has been firm on this.
Most people, the ones that are healthy
and not sick do not need
a mask at this time.
Notice that I approached that subject
with a level of humility.
I wasn't certain that masks wouldn't help.
The best evidence at the time told us
that masks wouldn't help
and it was true then;
however, now we know something different,
and that something different is
just because someone is healthy
doesn't mean they can't
be spreading the virus.
In the beginning of this pandemic,
people thought by wearing
masks they'd protect themselves
so we said, "No, that's wrong,"
but now we recommend
masks not to protect you,
the person wearing the mask,
but to limit you, as a
person who looks healthy,
from spreading the virus
into the environment.
So by everyone wearing a mask,
we're protecting the
community not the wearer.
In addition, in the
beginning of the pandemic,
we had a huge shortage of surgical masks
and N95 masks in the hospital setting
where we were working directly
with COVID-19 patients,
and medical providers were
dying as a result of that.
I still stand by my guidance at the time
even though it wasn't accurate.
It was based off the best
evidence at the time.
Will it change?
Yes.
Will I be afraid to tell
you that it's changed?
No, because I want you
to constantly be updated.
Looking at the most recent research,
we've seen that actually wearing masks,
even that cheap and
expensive surgical masks
or fabric face coverings
really does limit the spread
of this specific virus.
That's why it upsets me so
to walk around New York City
and see all these people not wearing masks
when they're in crowds of people.
Look, if you're walking
out into your backyard
and no one's there, you don't need a mask.
If you live in a remote area
where you're not gonna run into anybody,
you don't need a mask; however,
if you're going out to a crowded area,
you have to wear a mask.
I'd like to also touch on a subject
that I think many doctors
and health organizations
are avoiding talking about,
and that's how protests are
affecting COVID-19 numbers.
We can't, as health care institutions,
go out and say, "Hey do not
have any social gatherings
"unless you're protesting a just cause."
We can't say that, that's not accurate.
If you have a huge social
gathering of thousands of people,
you're putting your life at risk
and potentially the lives
of who you will encounter
throughout your next days.
When you're protesting,
try and keep six feet away from others.
If you're gonna be chanting or singing,
make sure the mask is covering your face.
For the next two weeks
do your best to stay away
from vulnerable populations:
those over the age of 60
or with immunocompromised states.
And after you protest, please,
please, go and get tested.
Because the last thing we want you to do
is to be one of those
people who are asymptomatic
or pre-symptomatic and
are spreading this virus
to thousands of people.
The virus unfortunately, doesn't care
if there are racial injustices
occurring in this country.
I hate that these racial
injustice is occurring.
The medical community
stands with the protests
but we have to be objective and still say
that by protesting you're
putting your life at risk.
Look, I get it, we're burned out.
We've been sitting at home
for close to three months now,
not being able to go do
the things that we enjoy,
not being able to see our loved ones,
not being able to find work
and struggling to pay rent
and securing food, I get it.
What you're experiencing
is called caution fatigue.
There's even a medical term for it
and we in the medical community experience
something similar called alarm fatigue.
We're in the ER and there's
constant alarm bells ringing,
we stopped paying attention
to them and that's a problem.
I think media constantly giving you
an outbreak warning every single day,
telling you that there's a
new coronavirus high number
has burned you out to the
point where you tune it out
and that's a problem because
I need you to stay alert
but I also need you to
stay active not anxious.
I recommended a couple of
videos for you here to watch
and as always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)